[MUSIC PLAYING]
ZOLTAN ACS: Our flagship project
is our nonprofit [INAUDIBLE]
Accelerator Program,
the mentoring program,
in which we are focusing on the
topics and the sectors which
can have significant social
impact on the society,
has on sports,
urbanism, and mobility
and working and learning.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOZEF VODICKA: Google
Developer's Launchpad
is mentor-driven event where
mentors have one-on-one session
with startups.
And they exchange the
ideas, and mainly, they--
mentors are trying to teach
startups how to think.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HANOCH RABINOVITZ:
The event was really--
it was fascinating.
I mean, I know Budapest is sort
of waking up with the startup
scene, startup ecosystem.
So, it was super interesting
to be a guest in this city.
DOROTTYA GAL: Budapest
is a good place
to launch your startup
because it's really
booming city, both culturally
and from an economic
perspective as well.
It's very good value
for money to live here.
There are a lot
of skilled people,
so you can find co-founders,
if you're missing a skill,
very easily.
So, it's worth to come here.
DAVID SARLOS: During
the one-on-one sessions,
I have learned a new
phrase, which is invalidate.
And we've been talking
so much about validation
that invalidation
seems to be, like,
a huge revelation, the big
relief in understanding
what phrase are we headed to,
and what is there to challenge?
DANIEL VATTAY: What I really
liked about this event
is that the focus
was quite different.
And thus the companies
that came were
solving real problems, problems
that I could stand behind,
problems that I can
support being solved.
To put it another way,
they are creating value
that I think is valuable.
[MUSIC PLAYING]